the year was 1983 and seven-year-old
andrea bradbury was wandering the
streets of nashville tennessee
one of her favorite activities was to
head down to the local movie theater and
fantasize about the movies she'd one day
be old enough to see
this fateful weekend andreas local
theater was playing a brand new release
jaws 3d what she didn't know is that
this simple
innocent activity would bring little
andrea into dangerous contact with
scp-178 and change her life forever
jaws 3d isn't exactly a classic it was
one of the many forgettable sequels
pumped out to cash in on the 3d craze of
the early 1980s
people paid extra for the privilege of
sitting in the dark with an
uncomfortable pair of cardboard glasses
while cheesy effects leapt out of the
screen towards them
many of the moviegoers simply threw away
the cheap disposable glasses
as soon as they left the theater leaving
them scattered on the sidewalk outside
seeing a pair of 3d glasses on the
ground right there for the taking
was the highlight of little andrea's wig
she may not have been old enough to see
any of the movies
but she knew that a local shop sold
books with images that popped out of the
page with a simple pair of 3d glasses
excited by the prospect of getting to
experience 3d
andrea grabbed a pair of glasses and ran
straight for the bookstore
later that night she was in her bedroom
with a stereoscopic image of a ferris
wheel
andrea adjusted the glasses and the
ferris wheel really did pop right off
the page
she marveled at the image coming out of
the book and felt like she could almost
touch it
but suddenly a strange feeling came over
her
she had the feeling that she wasn't
alone
still wearing the glasses andrea looked
up from her book and saw it
standing in the corner of her room
something huge
something monstrous andrea's parents
heard her scream and came rushing into
her room
there was their little girl dead it
looked like she'd been mauled to death
by a wild animal
but there was no sign of her killer the
windows were shut tight
unable to be open from the outside it
was like whatever horrible creature had
done this had vanished into
thin air the coroner's report didn't
give any other clues as to who could
have done this
except that whoever or whatever had
murdered her
it appeared to have three long and
incredibly sharp claws
the terrible tragedy of andrea's death
rocked nashville but it never made the
national papers
why because the scp foundation was
immediately on the case
undercover agents in the u.s fish and
wildlife service flagged the strange
death as anomalous
and scp field personnel arrived to do
their own investigation of the crime
scene
there they quickly discovered andrea's
3d glasses which would eventually be
classified
as scp-178 an agent looked over the
glasses
there didn't seem to be anything out of
the ordinary about them
just your regular cardboard frames with
blue and red tinted film over the eyes
everything about them seemed normal so
he tried the glasses on for himself
he picked up the open book off the
ground where andrea had likely dropped
it
and saw the ferris wheel pop off the
page nothing abnormal
until he turned his head slightly
he saw the head of some kind of thing
only an inch away from his own looking
over his shoulder at the book
being a trained scp agent he maintained
his composure
and looked around the room as he did he
saw that several other creatures were
standing and watching
none of the rest of the recovery team
seemed to notice the creatures
and when the agent removed scp-178 they
vanished
it appeared they had found whatever had
caused andrea bradbury's death
the glasses were immediately taken to
the nearest foundation containment site
for further testing
seeing these mysterious entities through
scp-178 may have answered one question
but it raised many others what are these
creatures
were they real or merely illusions
created by scp-178
if they are real are they somehow
summoned by scp-178 or simply revealed
by them
there was already one death that could
be tied to the glasses with some
certainty
but just how dangerous were they the scp
foundation
was about to find out foundation
scientists devised a series of
experiments
with a test chamber separated from an
adjoining observation chamber by a panel
of reinforced bulletproof glass
a member of d-class personnel was placed
into the test chamber
along with scp-178 he was instructed to
put on the glasses and report back what
he saw to the researchers
the d-class followed the orders however
when he did so
he quickly entered a state of extreme
distress he threw away the glasses and
covered his eyes screaming wildly
when ordered to compose himself and
explain what he saw under threat of
termination
the d-class described a hideous creature
standing close to his face
watching when asked to elaborate he
described it as having too
many eyes after that the d-class refused
to put the glasses back
on again despite direct orders and
threats from foundation staff
he was then removed from the test
chamber and observed although he
experienced two days of mild paranoia
after 30 total days of observation the
d-class was found to have no lasting
psychological effects
disappointed by the meager results of
the first test the researchers had at
least confirmed that they did have an
anomalous
object in their possession and pressed
on with experimentation
they used the same methodology again on
another d-class
she was placed into the chamber and
instructed to put on scp-178
then describe the entity she saw in
great detail
when she put on the glasses she recoiled
in horror at the monster she saw staring
back at her
she said that the creature was tall and
bipedal with two additional upper
appendages ending in large conical
protrusions
she also described the creature's head
as being smooth
when asked if the creature exhibited any
kind of aggression or hostility
she said that it was completely still it
was just standing there
after a few minutes though the creature
seemed to lose interest
and begin staring at the wall the
researchers were happy to learn more
about the creature's physicality
but they still weren't confident that it
wasn't just an illusion created by the
glasses
they needed to engineer an interaction
for the next experiment they decided to
alter the particulars
a fractal blue and red image in a
similar style to the stereoscopic ferris
wheel from the book
andrea had purchased was fixed to one
wall against the opposite wall
they placed a bucket containing 10
standard tennis balls
this time the d-class a convicted
murderer and arsonist was told he was
helping to test a new 3d augmented
reality project
the entities he would see as far as he
knew were little more than digital
projections
though when he actually wore scp-178 and
saw them
he commented that whoever designed them
must be crazy
the researchers instructed the d-class
to pick up a tennis ball and throw it at
one of the entities
the second he did so deep lacerations
began appearing
all over his body the onslaught was
brutal and quick
and the d-class was dead soon after that
this confirmed to the researchers that
the creatures did seem to have some
level of tangible presence
and they could be extremely violent if
provoked next
they wished to see if it was possible to
have any kind of interaction with the
creatures
without it immediately descending into
violence
to test this theory the researchers
brought a 19 year old d-class into the
testing chamber under the same pretense
of testing new 3d technology much like
the others she was still horrified by
the appearance of the creatures
but was calmed down by the researchers
they asked her to speak to the creatures
directly
without exhibiting any kind of
aggression she said
hello weird thing how are you today in a
somewhat bored voice
and this was all it took to sign her
death warrant she was immediately
slashed to death by invisible creatures
the results seemed clear any interaction
whatsoever with the creatures while
wearing scp-178 was a death sentence
like a slightly more outgoing shy guy
but the researchers would soon find that
this anomaly had
even more surprises for their next test
they brought in two subjects one would
wear scp-178 and dictate to the other
how they should interact with the
creature they could not see
the results of this experiment were
bloody yet informative
both subjects were slashed to death when
the unseen d-class interacted with one
of the creatures on her companion's
instructions
it appeared that anyone with sufficient
knowledge of the creatures who attempts
to interact with them
is doomed even if they can't directly
see one of them
it was an upsetting realization for the
researchers
scp-178 may be much more dangerous than
they initially imagined
and what they learned in the next
experiment was even worse
they adopted the same methodology as the
last for the following experiment
two subjects one seeing and the other
interacting
however this time as soon as subject
number one put on the glasses
they knew that something was terribly
wrong he began panicking
stating that the entire chamber was full
of the creatures all standing and
watching
the researchers undertook these
experiments knowing that they didn't
often turn out well for the d-class
so they didn't seem too worried about
this new development that is until the
subject stated that they could see
three more of the creatures and they
weren't
in the test chamber they were in the
observation room
in fact one of them was looking right
over one of the three researchers
shoulders
immediately the researchers lost
composure and began to panic
they were used to putting d-class in
danger that was part of the job
but they weren't prepared for this in
just moments the observation room became
a bloodbath
as the three researchers who'd been
designing and performing all the
experiments were torn to pieces by
creatures they couldn't see
scp-178 had gone from being one of the
more
innocent looking anomalies to one of the
most mysterious
and deadly the creatures seem to be
powerful
violent and incredibly numerous the fact
that they can only be observed through
178 stereoscopic lenses and kill anyone
who even attempts to interact with them
makes them almost
impossible to understand it was always a
tragedy when the foundation lost good
researchers
but the work must continue and the
experiments were
soon restarted with increased safety
measures of course those didn't do much
good
and after another disastrous experiment
that resulted in the whole sector
getting locked down
all research into scp-178 was placed
under
increased scrutiny they needed to find
some way of observing the creatures
without the risk of having to share
space with them the proposed solution
was seeing if the scp-178 glasses were
compatible with camera technology for
remote viewing
much like all stereoscopic glasses they
found that looking through only one lens
at a time was ineffective
the solution was relatively simple a
dual lens camera in a roughly similar
configuration
to human eyes this however didn't give
them the comfort or the answers they
hoped for
researchers commented upon finally
seeing the creatures
that they were even more hideous than
they'd ever imagined
as they observed a victim interacting
with the creatures via their new camera
they found that as soon as the creatures
were interacted with in any way
they would grow three long claws and
attack and they were as fast as they
were
ferocious from the observations there
were only a few things that the
foundation now knew about them for sure
their physical appearance
their violent nature their enhanced
physical abilities
and the fact they appear to be pretty
much everywhere
and who knows how long they'd been here
observing us humans while we glided by
them
ignorant to their presence it's enough
to make you think twice before putting
on a pair of 3d glasses again
but of course never putting on the
glasses doesn't mean you're safe
just knowing about them puts you in
danger
they could be standing next to you right
now looking over your shoulder as you
watch this video
just remember if you want to be safe
you can't ever let them know you're
aware after all
just because you can't see something
doesn't mean
it can't hurt now go check out scp-049
the plague doctor captured
and scp-087 the stairwell for some other
creepy creatures from scp explained